sur les campus universitaires se dessine
une autre crise à la suite de la
pandémie l'insécurité alimentaire qui
touche de plus en plus d'étudiants
en moyenne 40 à 48% des étudiants du
postsecondaire disent être en insécurité
alimentaire grave dit il
ce qui veut dire qu'ils sautent au moins
un repas par jour son organisme mire
exchange a mené une étude sur plusieurs
campus à travers le pays de nombreux
étudiants n'ont pas pu compter sur leur
emploi à temps partiel pour subvenir à
leurs besoins de base aux coûts des
étudiants travaillent dans la saq tarasp
et à l'est et donc
pas trop raide à l'emploi l'été passe il
a aussi fallu payer des frais de
scolarité qui ont augmenté et nous avons
lancé une crise date au canada sans jahn
ap plus du double car elle est étudiante
étrangère
j'ai trouvé ça difficile d'avoir accès à
de la nourriture raconte elle car je
vivais loin de tout et du campus et je
ne pouvais pas me payer de repas dehors
le prix des aliments a aussi bondi
nous estimons que les prix des denrées
alimentaires ont augmenté d'environ 5%
en raison de l'inflation dit elle
notamment en raison de mauvaises
conditions météorologiques causant des
interruptions de travail et de livraison
et un feu
l'utilisateur moyen d'une banque
alimentaire environ 1 9 dollar par jour
pour vivre après avoir payé son loyer
explique-t-il si vous ajoutez à cela des
pertes d'emplois l'inflation qui grimpe
la seule issue est le recours aux
banques alimentaires son réseau des dix
brède ne sommes pas plus de 124 mille
cinq cents clients y viennent chaque
mois ce qu'il faut dit il c'est un
meilleur accès aux logements abordables
et des salaires décents côté étudiants
certains groupes milite pour la gratuité
des études post secondaires qu'on se
restaurent craint un meilleur accès à la
nourriture certains des centres
alimentaires ou les étudiants pourraient
faire leurs courses à moindre coût ici
qu amy faye raizen radio canada toronto